so I'll be okay when I get some payback
the enemies range so are you from Knight
Rider - a couple of hallmark movies
mehgan's had more than 30 acting roles
including blink and you might miss it
moments like playing a FedEx girl in
Horrible Bosses a bartender serving our
paths and remember me and Ashton
Kutcher's seat mates in a lot like love
from New York but one of Megan's first
acting jobs was on General Hospital it
probably didn't hurt that her dad was a
soaps lighting director I had to chart
right here dr. Lambert I don't see the
notation anywhere Megan always wanted to
get into acting here she is 15 years old
singing her heart out as Little Red
Riding Hood and her high school
production of into the woods who is your
talent crush Kerry Washington she's
amazing Megan selfie okay one two after
just one season as a Deal or No Deal
briefcase girl Megan landed her breakout
role in suits my callsign was 5 a.m.
today this is my last straw and then get
some sleep and then do it all again
tomorrow I've never watched since I've
never heard of Megan before everything
that I've learned about him I learned
through him as opposed to having grown
up around different news stories or
tabloid yes the news documented all of
Harry's rebellious life the spare air
admitting to underage drinking and
smoking pot in 2005 Harry made headlines
for wearing a Nazi armband to a costume
party myself down at my farm telling
other people done but then the day this
should been a certain amount of primacy
that one should expect of course Harry
learned a lot by watching his mom
Princess Diana in her own struggles with
royal life no matter was despite all of
the difficulties of growing up in that
limelight and on that stage she was
going to ensure that both of us
as normal life as possible Diana always
rooster call Prince Harry the naughty
one and I think she recognized the
rebellious streak that she had she saw
that in Harry and I suppose he has been
the ultimate royal rebel by leaving all
of this behind him